une signature enfin acté les communes de
trappes la verrière et plaisir ont
inscrits certains de leurs quartiers
dans le nouveau programme national de
renouvellement urbain dans
l'agglomération ce sont vingt-cinq mille
habitants qui vont pouvoir bénéficier de
nouveaux aménagements sa marque je
dirais le départ de ce nouveau
renouvelle face au nouveau programme de
renouvellement urbain qui fait partie
des grands projets de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines de façon à
rééquilibrer son territoire en matière
d'offre de logement une première phase
de conception des projets qui permettra
à l' agence nationale pour la rénovation
urbaine d'établir les plus j'ai accordé
à chaque commune l' agence qui dispose
d'une enveloppe passer de cinq à dix
milliards d'euros récemment à répartir
sur 200 quartier au niveau national
l'intérêt de cette phase de
préfiguration de dire ben on va porter
le niveau d'ambition à ce niveau-là et
de discuter si on est capable de
l'accompagner jusqu'où et c'est sur
cette base là que se font les enveloppes
reconstruction de logements sociaux à
trappes nouvelle entrée de ville à la
verrière désenclavement du quartier du
val hibou à plaisir autant de projets
d'envergure pour les communes et qui
nécessiteront un travail de concertation
avec les habitants pourront démarrer le
projet l'estimation de ses financements
sur une l'idée politico technique je
veux dire c'est pour et mais après il ya
le travail eux qui les habitants c'est
avec les habitants qu'on veut faire le
projet c'est avec eux qu'on va améliorer
la situation sur place
on est vraiment je dirais heureux d'être
ici tous ensemble ça veut dire que
véritablement il ya un intérêt par
rapport à ces trois villes puisque trois
villes qui sont impactés maintenant on
attend la suite et on attend des choses
concrètes
un processus qui s'inscrit dans un temps
long ces deux premières améliorations
devraient être visibles dès 2019
les rénovations devraient s'étendre au
moins jusqu'en 2024